[Musique]
nous sommes le 20 septembre 2016 merci
de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 les invités et voici justement
les invités du jour bruno myle yens le
président du modem des yvelines il
revient sur la possibilité d'une
candidature de son parti aux
législatives les troupes de françois
bayrou ne se rallieront à derrière le
candidat de la droite uniquement que si
il s'agit là jean luc roux le maire
adjoint en charge de la prévention et de
la sécurité en continu le bretonneux se
prononce sur l'annulation des animations
et des manifestations en raison de la
menace terroriste est les points de vue
divergent certains entendent faire acte
de résistance
nous parlons donc de politique pour
débuter et le modem des yvelines qui
affiche son ambition pour 2017 à la
proche de l'élection présidentielle la
formation annonce vouloir se ranger
derrière le candidat de la droite
uniquement en cas de victoire à la
primaire d'alain juppé est si ces
derniers devaient être battus il y
aurait même donc des candidats aux
couleurs du parti centriste aux
législatives
explications avec bruno myle yens c'est
le président du modem dans le
département il est également conseiller
régional dans la majorité en ile de
france
au moment où on en est de la primaire de
la droite et de la campagne vous voyez
bien que le seul qui se soit déclaré
ouvertement pour un large rassemblement
ils appellent ça progressiste mais pour
sa large rassemblement humaniste
porteurs d'idées nouvelles
porteur de témoins vers une politique
autrement le seul qui l'ait fait c'est
alain juppé et ça correspond exactement
à tous qu'on prône depuis dix ans déjà
donc c'est naturellement qu'on va vers
lui les autres n'ont rien montré de tel
donc donc effectivement vers alain juppé
et en plus vous connaissez les liens
d'amitié qui le lie à françois bayrou
d'amitié de respect ces deux hommes
humainement ondes et ont des vues très
proches ce qui veut dire que si je vais
gagner la primaire c'est sur le modem à
se mettre devant le soutiendra oui oui
bien sûr on l'a dit on et on n'a pas
l'habitude de revenir sur notre parole
donc voilà des accords sont passés avec
deux parties
ça après on vient on en est pas là mais
il est bien évident que si alain juppé
prône un large rassemblement comme ça il
sera bien obligé de composer avec toutes
les composantes de ce rassemblement
oui il y aura forcément leur a forcément
d'accord si on le sait les jce latif que
j'y pensais bien évidemment il faudra
qu'il ait une majorité qui puisse le
perlage de gouverner donc il faudra
toutes les tendances représentées dans
son rassemblement soit présente à
l'assemblée nationale mais ça c'est
logique c'est le jeu démocratique qui
nous simples déjà on va essayer de se
remettre de remettre le l'essence même
du monde mandat de député ou au centre
du débat
c'est à dire que pour nous un député
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui et au niveau
et
au niveau de son territoire tout le
temps sur son territoire qui étudier ce
qui se passe en territoire qui essayent
de tester avec les élus avec la
population des solutions et quand ces
solutions sont réplicable au niveau
national ils essayent de les implémenter
dans un amendement de loi ou dans une
loi de manière à ce que à faire en sorte
que tout aille mieux je pense que alors
vous allez dire c'est un peu aussi le
travail des sénateurs mais très bien
mais je pense que certains députés ont
un peu oublié ça ils sont ceux qui sont
trop éloignés du terrain trop éloignés
de leurs électeurs trop éloigné du
quotidien de la réalité il faut qu'on
reviendra
alors sur les yvelines mais comme dans
les autres départements il ya plein de
thèmes du va falloir défendre
il va falloir défendre toute la partie
ruralité qui a été abandonné pendant des
années on vacille appelé et le passage
que je t'ai aujourd'hui à la région
tombe bien parce que je suis un
commission agriculture et réalité on
vient bientôt sortir un pacte un pacte
rural on travaille dessus
dans toutes ces expériences acquises
vont bien sûr servir à l'ensemble des
élus modem des yvelines puisque je fais
partager je fais les retours
d'expérience je peux partager mon
expérience à la région comme le font
d'ailleurs les élus sur d'autres
collectivités
la ruralité ça sera un thème très
important parce que malgré tout ce que
tous on est loin du compte
en ce qui concerne la ruralité et d
les communes rurales parce que on va
vers de plus en plus des désertification
vous le savez très bien
ce sont nos services publics au niveau
des médecins au niveau des entreprises
nouvelles activités économiques
tout ça ça disparaît il faut vraiment
connaître ces territoires
il va falloir qu'on retravaille aussi
dans le milieu urbain sur certaines
zones où je pense on a fait pendant trop
longtemps et je ne jette l'anathème sur
personne
tout le monde le faisait donc voilà mais
on a fait trop longtemps beaucoup de
clientélisme qui aujourd'hui provoque un
retour de boomerang qui fait que le
front national est aussi haut et que et
que aussi on a des problèmes de
communautarisme il va falloir qu'on
travaille sur imaginé
la ville et village les communes de
demain l'environnement va être un point
central aussi on ne va plus pouvoir
construire et aménager territoire comme
le fait aujourd'hui on le fait
aujourd'hui
il va falloir qu'on tienne compte de la
nature et des scripts l'année de la
biodiversité sinon on va tuer notre
planète non qu'il faut contre donc à
plein de thèmes là dedans
et tout ça bâtit autour d'un axe central
qui est le vivre ensemble et replacer
l'homme au centre du sujet qu'on prête
alors que certains pourraient être
surpris mais des devoirs que tout deux
modèles se saisit de proposer plus
candidate du cheminot pour ses erreurs
législatives
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
voient là je répondrai simplement que
parmi les candidats les 12000 home qu'on
a présenté la plupart d'entre eux sont
des élus déjà locaux qu'ils connaissent
leur territoire ça c'est première chose
deuxième chose c'est pas parce que on
les a pas vus à la télévision on n'a pas
entendu parler d'eux dans les journaux
on a pas on les a tant entendu à la
radio que ces gens là un non pas des
choses à dire d'eux non pas des explants
de très intéressante
les trois sont matin dans l'incapacité
de gérer des collectivités ou même
d'assumer un mandat de député je suis
désolé
je page pas enfoncé enfoncé mais
certains certains parlementaires mais
non non on les voit pas beaucoup à
l'assemblée nationale et on les voit pas
non plus avoir d'espoir donc pour
certaines choses je ne vois pas en quoi
les élus modem les candidats modèles
seraient moins bien que certains qui
sont déjà élus après la politique il est
question de sécurité de l'attitude à
adopter face à la menace terroriste pour
certains il faut éviter de prendre le
moindre risque pour d'autres
donc c'est faux pour d'autres il faut en
revanche s'affirmer et revendiquer la
mise en place des différentes
manifestations qu'on soit en jean luc
moreau je vous êtes le maire adjoint à
montigny le bretonneux en charge
justement de la sécurité de la
prévention
quel est votre point de vue sur la
question principe de précaution au
contraire il faut justement ça fermait
et revendiquer haut et fort les
différentes manifestations qui sont
organisées
alors je vais vous faire une réponse de
normand il faut en même temps s'affirmer
mais aussi prendre les dispositions qui
s'imposent si vous voulez à ce jour sur
montigny nous n'avons supprimer aucune
manifestation
par contre nous avons pris des
dispositions complémentaires bien
évidemment je laisse la partie scolaire
qui étaient traités en liaison avec les
consignes du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
mais pour les manifestations organisées
par la ville je vais prendre l'exemple
d'une fête de quartier qui auparavant se
faisait sur une place ouverte à tout le
monde
et bien les deux dernières fêtes de
quartier notamment à saint quentin ou
encore sur le village ont été faites
dans des enceintes d'école ce qui
permettait si vous voulez de sécuriser
l'accès de contrôler l'accès des
personnes et de protéger puisque les
cours d'école sont toutes clôturé de
protéger ainsi les personnes qui était
et qui étaient à l'intérieur pour suivre
cet entretien de nous expliquer un petit
peu plus au cas par cas comment vous
gérez ces différentes manifestations je
vous propose d'écouter un petit
micro-trottoir vous allez demander
justement s'il fallait ou non par
principe de précaution annuler les
différentes manifestations
j'ai en fait je pense que le fait
d'allumer d'annuler des événements ça
peut
par rapport au terrorisme c'est en fait
c'est leur donner raison à la sécurité
passe avant tout je crois faut annuler
des événements voir si ça pourrait bien
porter atteinte à un citoyen faudra tout
ennui c'est très bien d'annuler les
événements parce qu'il ya des priorités
on a besoin de la sécurité parce qu'on
n'est pas rassurés pour moi annuler des
événements juste par sécurité par
rapport aux attentes assez juste une
preuve que bas ils vont gagner il faut
pas qu'on les laisse nous déstabiliser
comme ça faut juste essayer de renforcer
la sécurité continue à vivre normalement
moi je pense que ça reste normal
d'aligner les événements par rapport à
la sécurité mais si je me dis
normalement ça doit être quelque chose
de temporaire
après oui c'est sûr que faudrait pas
parce que ça me prouve que on sera
baisse mais bon je pense c'est quand
même normal
comment se décide concrètement une
annulation de manifestations pour le
grand public c'est un peu obscures en
fait
alors si vous voulez nous avons depuis
les tragiques événements donc on a une
commission de sécurité en interne à la
mairie
et selon l'importance de la
manifestation selon nombre de personnes
qu'on accueille si c'est une fête de
quartier je vais dire 3 400 500
personnes c'est une chose si c'est le
marché de noël qu'on va voir la fin de
l'année où on aura quinze mille
personnes c'est autre chose
donc chaque événement donne lieu à une
réunion de la commission de sécurité en
interne et nous communiquons bien
évidemment parce que c'est une
obligation maintenant nous communiquons
avec la préfecture des yvelines
les mesures que nous prenons nous
validons avec la préfecture des yvelines
le dispositif mis en place mais la
préfecture peut vous imposer
l'annulation d'une manifestation
c'est à l'appréciation du
la responsabilité du maire dénoncé la
préfecture peu au tout dernier moment
dire non vous ne ferez pas cette
manifestation parce qu'il s'est
malheureusement passé quelque chose en
france
bon papa par rapport à nos discussions
qu'on a prise puisque l on été j'irai
travailler et concerté avec la
préfecture mais si l'actualité nous
amener à annuler le préfet c'est lui qui
a autorité peut décider au tout dernier
moment d'annuler une manifestation
le marché de noël que vous avez évoqué
pour l'instant on doit se tenir alors le
marché de noël on n'a pas envie encore
aime beaucoup de monde au delà montini
voilà donc le marché de noël il ya une
population des yvelines mais bien au
delà on a à peu près quinze mille
personnes sur trois jours
donc nous avons déjà une autre petite
réunion en interne mais il est sûr qu'on
va prendre des dispositions que je
n'irai pas ici sur le plateau pour les
ongles vous pouvez comprendre
on va prendre des dispositions nouvelles
pour sécuriser au maximum l'accès des
des clients on va les appeler comme ça
l'accès des personnes qui vont venir au
marché de noël ce qui nous protège
beaucoup c'est qu'on a la chance d'avoir
les commerçants dans la cour de la ferme
donc elle est déjà fermé entente l1 puis
tous les exposants artisanaux à
l'intérieur de la grange donc voila mais
on a quand même quinze mille personnes
et ça aujourd'hui plus qu'hier on est
obligé de le prendre en compte c'est
peut-être aussi un facteur un peu
subjectif mais est ce que vous prenez en
compte la fatigue des forces de l'ordre
qui sont quand même très sollicités puis
on en viendra aussi au travail de la
police municipale qui elles aussi mises
à contribution
oui alors prenez en compte alors oui on
est obligé de le prendre en compte parce
qu'effectivement depuis de nombreux mois
ils sont ils sont en permanence seul
seul sur le terrain
donc il ya deux deux aspects à votre
question il ya la police nationale
et il ya aussi une opération sentinel
donc l'armée qui y patrouille mais je
dirais aujourd'hui vu les renforts qui a
eu je parle de ce que je connais un
petit peu sur le département des
yvelines
bon on n'a pas si vous voulez j'ai
rencontré avec monsieur le maire les les
commissaires de police pas plus tard
qu'avant-hier dont il n'y a pas ce
sentiment de de fatigue comme on
pourrait l'imaginer sur paris ou qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup plus de tensions
sur paris mais c'est un une donnée qu'il
nous faut prendre en compte ça c'est sûr
la police municipale qui à de nouveaux
moyens cette année puisque vous avez
équiper les forces de l'ordre municipale
de tasers notamment puis il ya un
renforcement du dispositif de
vidéosurveillance vidéoprotection tout à
fait alors là si vous voulez c'est sûr
que notre police municipale est soumise
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de beaucoup de
demandes bon donc nous avons il ya un an
un peu plus d'un an la main renforcée
par une brigade canine avec deux maîtres
chiens et cette année nous équipons la
poésie cipal de taser pour l'instant en
fait on va dire pistolet électrique
taser c'est une marque
pour l'instant nous ne voulons pas
équiper nos policiers avec des armes
pistolets
débat dans chacune il ya des débats dans
chaque mairie après chaque maire prend
la décision selon les risques qu'il
estime nous nous en nous sommes au
pistolet électrique qui est plus pour
nous certes une arme mais surtout un
moyen d'intimidation par rapport à
certains individus qui voudraient gérer
comme être soit des haltes soit agresser
la police municipale ou agressé d'autres
personnes merci donc c'est un moyen qui
va être déployé
on vient de les doter mais il faut là il
faut les former ça va être bientôt
déployée sur la ville vous allez vous
remercier parce qu'on arrive au terme de
cette suite les invités mais juste d'un
à précisions sur la vidéoprotection là
aussi un renforcement alors la
vidéoprotection oui on a déjà 65 caméras
sur la ville de montigny on est à la
pointe au niveau des yvelines et on va
encore en rajouter sur la place
georges pompidou pour protéger encore
enfin vidéosurveillées cette zone encore
plus merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités ripley
disponibles de cette édition et des
précédentes elle sur notre site internet
dès à présent rendez vous demain
mercredi 18h45 pour la première
diffusion du prochain 7 8 invités avec
florane parfait qui recevra notamment la
christiane buisson de la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines et
puis il sera aussi question de la soirée
quartier caritative organisée par
l'hôpital
mignot au chesnay
[Musique]